when a film is really great and I'm you
know it draws me in I forget about the
fact that I know about making movies and
I forget the fact that I've been there
and done things I mean there's it's I
mean even with films that you've done I
mean like you know I was talking about
the Black Stallion I mean when you
suddenly see it with an audience and
it's you know it's working and the
audience is liking it you almost forget
that you were working on it I mean
that's the great thing is that I I hope
I never get to the point where I am so
involved in the process of making movies
that I can no longer enjoy going to
movies because to be honest with you I
love going to movies and I see lots and
lots of movies every year I mean right
now because it's the end of the year and
I'm involved in the Foreign Language
Film Committee I'm seeing lots of
foreign films and it's really wonderful
and some are fantastic and some are okay
but they're always interesting to see
and yeah I mean I'd I don't I don't look
at movies from a technical point of view
I don't look at movies from you know an
over-critical point of view I really
just want to go to the movies and be
entertained and then maybe after I've
seen it once I will review it and go see
it again if I really liked it and try to
figure out why it is that I liked it but
I mean I still love going to movies it's
it's great